Новини «heute» з Яною Парайґіс.
Доброго вам вечора.
Вони зробили це, німецькі
футболістки вчора ввечері, Норберте.
Перемога у півфіналі проти Франції
і тепер дев'ятий титул
чемпіонів Європи зовсім близько.
Наші головні теми сьогодні:
Газ подорожчає:
З жовтня споживачі газу
мають платити податок.
Міністр економіки Габек
розраховує на кілька сотень
євро з кожної сім'ї.
Життя у кредит:
Ніколи ще людство не витрачало
ресурси Землі так швидко,
як цього року.
Омріяний фінал неперевершений:
перемігши Францію з рахунком 2:1,
німецькі футболістки виходять
у фінал чемпіонату
Європи проти Англії.
Тим, хто користується газом,
з жовтня доведеться розщедритися:
з цього моменту всі будуть повинні
сплачувати податок на газ.
У наступні півтора року.
Це означає,
що до кожної кіловат-години
буде додано від 1,5 до 5 центів.
Точна сума має бути відома
до середини-кінця серпня.
Зрештою, сума може досягти
кількох сотень євро на рік.
Докладніше розповість Франк Бухвальд.
Почесний гість у котельні.
Міністр економіки Гіссена відвідує
сім'ю Кірбергів в Ідштайні.
Вся справа в економії енергії.
Опалення суттєво
подорожчає, це очевидно.
Однак у жовтні буде
запроваджено додаткове нарахування.
Для Майї та Даніеля Кірберга
зараз його важко підрахувати.
Здається, це дуже великий тариф,
який йде до нас.
Я не знаю, чи це буде зрештою
на користь споживача.
Як і Кірберги, усі ті,
хто опалюється газом, -
а в Німеччині це щонайменше
кожен другий - відчувають те саме.
Навіть віцеканцлер
не може точно сказати,
яким буде розмір нарахування.
Точно буде недешево.
Ми очікуємо,
що вартість становитиме
від 1,5 до 5 центів за
кіловат-годину.
Треба порахувати.
Якщо середнє споживання
становить 20 000 кіловат-годин,
ми опинимося в діапазоні
близько сотні євро.
Причина: Росія майже
не постачає більше газу,
довгострокові контракти розриваються.
Такі постачальники як «Uniper» змушені
отримувати запасні партії, що в рази дорожче.
Багато муніципальних комунальних
служб перебувають на межі банкрутства,
і це нарахування
покликане їх врятувати.
Опозиція попереджає
про соціальний дисбаланс.
Нам потрібна конкретна
ініціатива федерального уряду,
аби прицільно допомогти людям
із малими та середніми доходами,
а не лише тим,
хто отримує житлову допомогу.
Багато мешканців вже сплачують
набагато вищі тарифи за опалення.
Асигнування, ймовірно,
лише посилить цей тягар.
Сьогодні нам відомо, що податок
на газ запроваджується з 1 жовтня.
І тому ми хотіли б почекати з
оголошенням про підвищення тарифів.
Це має відбутися в серпні.
Це правда, що федеральний уряд
допомагає багатьом людям матеріально,
надаючи енергетичну
допомогу або житлові субсидії.
Але захисники прав
споживачів хочуть більшого.
Коли асигнування набуде
чинності першого жовтня,
то має бути готовим
пакет допомоги для тих,
хто не має таких великих доходів
щоб вони змогли легко пережити зиму.
Житло в Німеччині недешеве,
і, швидше за все,
воно ще подорожчає.
Це соціально небезпечно,
навіть для багатої країни.
Інфляція в Німеччині трохи знизилася
в липні другий місяць поспіль.
Товари та послуги коштували
в середньому на 7,5% дорожче,
ніж минулого року, повідомило
Федеральне відомство статистики.
Найбільш вразливими, як і раніше,
є дорогі продукти харчування
та витрати на електроенергію.
Насторожує той факт, що одразу
кілька енергетичних компаній
повідомили про значні прибутки
у першому півріччі.
Штефані Барет повідомляє
з Франкфуртської фондової біржі.
З моменту початку війни
в Україні нафтові компанії
опинилися серед великих
антикризових підприємств.
Вони одержують великі гроші.
Через санкції російська нафта
опинилася у дефіциті.
Це призвело до зростання
вартості нафти на світовому ринку.
Багато нафтопереробних
заводів закрилися,
тому що був попит на уникнення
нафти як викопного палива.
Перш за все нафтові транснаціональні
корпорації заробляють на
торгівлі власною
електроенергією та газом.
Тільки за останні місяці
прибуток найбільшої в Європі
нафтової компанії «Shell»
подвоївся
у порівнянні з попереднім роком,
як і прибуток французького
енергетичного гіганта «Total».
Загалом нафтові компанії
заробляють чудово.
Ймовірно, це стане причиною дебатів
шодо частки нафтових транснаціональних
корпорацій у покритті витрат.
Одні країни Європи вже
вираховують прибуток з асигнувань.
Інші ж планують перевести
оподаткування прибутку.
Комісія ЄС уже дала зелене
світло на запровадження
тимчасового податку на прибуток.
Практично день у день Міністерство економіки
змінює правила щодо того,
що підлягає фінансовій підтримці,
як у випадку ремонту будівель.
У деяких випадках це
діє вже сьогодні.
Для індивідуальних заходів,
таких як заміна вікон, - від 15 серпня
У всіх банках ставки субсидій
було знижено.
Аргумент: у результаті
цього виграє більше людей.
Причина скорочень:
обмежений бюджет.
Що саме широко критикується -
у репортажі Свена Рікена.
Зараз Хеннінг Баалманн
та його команда
встановлюють переважно
теплові помпи.
Неймовірне зростання цін на газ
та високі субсидії
викликали величезний попит.
Але тепер зрозуміло:
грошей на встановлення
теплових помп поменшало.
Проблема може торкнутися
багатьох будівельників.
Той факт, що до 20% субсидій,
які розраховані на
компенсацію цих витрат,
будуть втрачені у разі їх відсутності,
безумовно, коштуватиме деяким
людям їхнього перетворення.
Федеральний уряд не лише скорочує
виплати на теплові помпи.
Наприклад, на встановлення
нових вікон держава надасть
лише 20% інвестицій
замість обіцяних 25%.
Це означає зменшення вартості
квартири максимум на 3000 євро.
14 млрд. євро має вистачити
на масштабніші індивідуальні заходи.
Критика: це майже не
сприяє захисту довкілля.
Нам потрібна реконструкція,
що відповідає кліматичним цілям,
і якнайшвидше.
Але те, що ми бачимо де-факто,
- це скорочення фінансування.
Це означає, що ми продовжуватимемо
упускати кліматичні цілі,
яких ми вже не досягли у
будівельному секторі за останні роки.
Це вже третя зміна у
субсидіях за цей рік.
Щоразу компаніям
доводиться робити перерахунок,
щоразу заходи дорожчають
через постійне зростання вартості
матеріалів та процентних ставок.
За підрахунками фахівців
галузі, для того, щоб
справді провести екологічну реконструкцію,
потрібно 100 мільярдів євро на рік.
Якщо ви співвіднесете субсидію
із загальною ситуацією - добре,
якщо вона принесе
користь декільком людям, -
то різниця становитиме близько 7 %.
Але решта 93% мають бути кимось оплачені.
І це зрештою
позначиться на вартості житла.
Експерт із теплових насосів Баалман
бачить ще одну проблему
енергоефективного ремонту:
терміни постачання.
Клієнтам, які замовляють у нього
сьогодні теплові помпи,
зараз доводиться чекати пів року.
Попит різко зростає.
До новин України.
Доки країна святкує
свій День державності,
російська армія продовжує атакувати
саме цю українську суверенність.
Сьогодні, вперше за
кілька тижнів, Київська
та Чернігівська області знову
зазнали бомбардування.
Франциска фон Тізенхаузен
повідомляє про те,
наскільки небезпечною
є ситуація навіть там,
де українська армія
повністю контролює ситуацію.
Те, що російська армія зробила
за шість місяців у Сумах,
на північному сході країни,
показали нашій знімальній групі
співробітники
Національної гвардії України
під час престуру.
У квітні російські
війська були виведені,
але тут небезпечно, як і раніше.
Не тільки через міни, а й тому,
що регіон неодноразово
зазнавав обстрілів.
Це ще одна причина,
через яку Президент Зеленський
говорить про мужність своїх
співгромадян у цей День державності.
Ми будемо жити, щоб боротися,
і боротися, щоб жити.
Ми не здамося,
доки не проженемо зі свого
дому останнього окупанта.
За словами Зеленського,
Україна втратила контроль
за 20% своєї території.
На Півдні набирає обертів
контрнаступ
на окуповане місто Херсон,
за даними Міністерства
оборони Великої Британії.
В повідомленні також йдеться про те,
шо поблизу міста
було пошкоджено три мости,
від яких залежить
просування військ Росії.
Завдяки такому втручанню Херсон
стає відрізаним від решти регіону.
Російська сторона заперечує це.
Це нас не зупинить,
це знищення нічого не дає і не ﻿доводить,
що ці нацисти не просуватимуться на Херсон.
Місто окуповане з березня.
У вересні призначена військова
адміністрація хоче провести референдум
про приєднання
до Російської Федерації.
Українська сторона
хоче цьому запобігти.
Повернімося до Німеччини:
у червні 2019 року президент
округу Кассель Вальтер Любке
був убитий правим
екстремістом Стефаном Ернстом.
Ернст був засуджений
до довічного ув'язнення.
Другий обвинувачений Маркус Х.,
також правий екстреміст,
був виправданий за звинуваченням
у співучасті та підбурюванні.
Усі сторони подали апеляції.
Нині вирок розглядається
Федеральним верховним судом
щодо юридичних помилок.
Репортаж Сари Такке
та Крістофера Шнайдера.
Важкий шлях для родини
Любке до Верховного суду.
Знову йдеться про вбивство
чоловіка та батька.
Півтора року тому правого
екстреміста Стефана Ернста
засудили до довічного ув'язнення
за вбивство Вальтера Любке -
суд залишив за ним право
на попереднє ув'язнення.
Для франкфуртських
суддів було очевидно,
що у червні 2019 Ернст
віроломно застрелив Вальтера Любке
на терасі його будинку
на півночі Гіссена,
керуючись расистськими
та ксенофобськими мотивами.
Окрім Ернста,
співучасник злочину Маркус Х.
був засуджений лише
за незаконне володіння зброєю,
хоча федеральний суд
звинуватив його
у пособництві та підбурюванні
до вбивства Любке.
Родині Любке такий м'який
вирок незрозумілий,
оскільки містить безліч помилок.
По-перше: наявні прогалини у вироку,
кричущі прогалини в письмовому вироку.
По-друге,
застосовано неправильні норми доказового права.
По-третє: практично цілковита ненаявність
загальної оцінки.
Емоційним був момент під час слухання,
коли вдова Вальтера Любке зверталася до суду.
Зі сльозами на очах вона згадувала слова,
які завжди казав їй чоловік:
що для нього велике щастя жити в країні,
де можна вільно висловлювати свою думку.
Зрештою, саме таке переконання
коштувало чоловікові життя,
що ще раз показує величезний
соціальний вимір ﻿цієї процедури.
Рішення Вищого кримінального суду Німеччини
щодо апеляції очікується в кінці серпня.
Німецькі залізниці знову отримують прибуток.
Якщо переглянути піврічний фінансовий звіт,
то стає цілком зрозуміло чому:
Міжнародна логістична дочірня компанія Schenker
принесла до каси мільярдний прибуток.
Загалом дохід залізниці за перші півроку
складає майже 876 млн євро,
з оборотом майже 28 млрд євро.
Про вагомі проблеми, які все ще наявні
в пасажирському транспорті,
незважаючи на стрімкий ріст кількість пасажирів,
розповість Гансюрґен Піль.
Поїзди знову переповнені пасажирами,
не тільки завдяки пільговим квиткам
за 9 євро в Regio, але також в Інтерсіті та ICE.
Майже 60 мільйонів мандрівників з січня.
Це майже стільки, скільки до пандемії.
Начальник залізниці вбачає в цьому переломний момент.
Ми повільно, але впевнено залишаємо позаду
пандемію Covid-19 та фінансові наслідки,
які були досить драматичними, і бачимо,що люди
повертаються до системи, іми можемо
надалі збільшувати наші доходи.
Кількість пасажирів зросла,
а пунктуальність поїздів, навпаки, знизилась.
У червні майже кожен 2-ий потяг далекого
сполучення запізнився більше ніж на шість хвилин.
Основна причина: на мережі рейкових шляхів ніколи
раніше не було так багато будівельних робіт.
Старі дороги, застаріла техніка, занедбана роками.
Великими зусиллями з 2030 року все має бути
пристосованим для перевезення вдвічі більшої
кількості пасажирів, до того ж завдяки роботі
на 850 будівельних майданчиках на день.
І це лише початок.
З наступного року почнуться комплексні роботи.
Тобто основні маршрути будуть
закриті на триваліший період часу.
Проблеми накопичувалася протягом 20 років.
І весь цей час ремонтні роботи переносили з року на рік.
А зараз на ремонт залізничної мережі
знадобиться багато років.
Ми повинні бути готовими до того,
що найближчими роками пунктуальність поїздів
не покращиться,
а сполучення найімовірніше буде перекрито для того,
щоб стабілізувати мережу взагалі.
Жодних хороших новин для пасажирів залізниці,
що подорожують у переповнених поїздах.
Відтепер людство взяло «кредит» у природи.
Це повідомлення пролунало на так званому
«Дні екологічного боргу».
Сьогодні всі природні ресурси,
які може замінити наша планета,
використовуються по всьому світу.
У багатьох індустріальних країнах
цей день відбувся раніше.
Наприклад, у Німеччині - 4 травня.
Щоб тенденція остаточно змінилася,
дослідники пропонують винахідливі рішення.
Марк Гуґо ділиться ідеями з галузі
сільського господарства.
Це яблуко - особливе.
Це частина ідеї,
яка незабаром допомогла б зберегти ресурси.
У цьому разі - хороший ґрунт.
Ідея насправді проста:
У верхній частині розташовані сонячні батареї, що
генерують електроенергію, знизу ростуть фрукти.
Так і тут, у цій експериментальній споруді
в Ґельсдорфі, що в Айфелі.
Великий плюс подвійного використання,
тому що зберігається сільськогосподарська земля,
яка є надзвичайно цінною
і яку насправді недооцінюють.
Але ми все ще маємо можливість генерувати
сонячну енергію,
яка тоді доступна нам для вирощування на полі.
Оновлена енергосистема допомагає зекономити на
вугіллі та газі.
І є ще одна перевага:
дах з сонячних батарей захищає від
сонця, сильних дощів та граду.
А втім, не кожному сорту яблук
підходить такий спосіб.
Це питання ще потрібно дослідити.
Ми знаємо, що культури по-різному реагують
не тільки на зниження частоти світла,
але й на зволоження за допомогою дощів.
Тому ми хочемо перевірити,
яким із цих восьми видів фруктів
найкраще підійде фотоелектрична техніка.
Наразі доведено, що система придатна для цих цілей.
Ця модель є частиною «сонячного наступу»
уряду Німеччини й фінансуватиметься
уже з наступного року.
Така модель є вигідною, як для фермерів,
так і для природи.
А зараз про лісові пожежі в Німеччині:
пожежу на півдні Бранденбурґа
наразі вдалося взяти під контроль.
Хоча екстрені служби все ще напружені:
вогонь не припиняє тліти.
Гірша ситуація на федеральних землях Саксонії.
У Саксонській Швейцарії продовжують
поширюватися пожежі.
Вночі спалахнула ще одна пожежа,
перетнувши кордон з Чехією.
Корнелія Шіменц розповість про боротьбу з вогнем.
Тільки зверху, у повітрі, можна побачити
масштаби катастрофи повністю.
Багато поодиноких пожеж
спалахують все частіше через вітер.
Загасити пожежі у скелястих долинах
Саксонської Швейцарії надзвичайно важко.
Гелікоптери злітають і приземляються
майже щохвилини,
щоб допомогти загасити велику пожежу
в Саксонській Швейцарії.
Застосовуються як цивільні гелікоптери,
так і гелікоптери, надані Бундесвером,
котрі борються
заради спільної мети - зупинити вогонь.
Міністр внутрішніх справ Саксонії скасував
свою відпустку.
Шокований трагедією, він стоїть посеред
національного парку
і обіцяє велику допомогу.
У будь-якому разі,ми використаємо всі ресурси,
якими володіє федеральна земля Саксонія.
Ми зробимо це, але це буде не так швидко,
як деякі очікують.
Сотні виснажених пожежників борються спільно з
пожежними гелікоптерами проти вогню.
Екстремально низький рівень води у річці Ельбі.
Чеська Республіка відкрила сьогодні шлюз
у верхів'ях Ельби, щоб протидіяти цьому.
Тепер більше води тече вниз по Ельбі.
Вода, яка терміново потрібна, щоб зупинити пожежу.
Мільйони людей вчора були прикутими до телевізорів.
Причина - перегляд висококласного півфіналу.
Німеччина у фіналі Чемпіонату Європи з футболу.
І це заслужена перемога жіночої збірної.
Тактичний майстерний хід проти сильних француженок,
великий командний дух і передусім видатний капітан,
Александра Попп, котра забила обидва голи.
Навіть після приїзду на нову локацію,
сьогодні ввечері всі в захваті від Александри Попп.
Це приголомшлива гра на такому сильному турнірі,
яка не може не надихати.
Команда вчора просто розчавила в обіймах супергероїню
після фінального свистка.
Александра Попп, цілком виснажена, але надщаслива.
Гол на 40-й хвилині сильною лівою ногою,
рахунок 1-0, який приносить її
команді відрив на п'ять хвилин.
Мерле Фромс вдалося забити гол до перерви.
Тому рахунок був нічийним
аж до 76-ї хвилини.
Тоді Попп забиває м'яч головою, здобувши
перемогу у фіналі
проти Англії на стадіоні Вемблі із рахунком 2:1.
Переможець 53 рази, чотириразовий чемпіон світу,
повідомив про відставку.
Себастьян Феттель, один з найуспішніших
автоперегонщиків
в історії Формули-1, позаду якого 53 перемоги,
завершує свою велику кар'єру після закінчення сезону.
35-річний перегонщик хоче більше
часу проводити з сім'єю.
Як інопланетянин:
Феттель у своєму рідному місті Геппенгаймі
на піку своєї кар'єри.
Минуло вже ціле десятиліття.
Бути успішним в спорті та добрим батьком і чоловіком
- ці речі більше не є поєднуваними для мене.
Роки в Red Bull приносять чотири
чемпіонських титули поспіль.
Як спортсмен року, Феттель показує своє коріння.
Але ні на Ferrari, ні на Aston Martin він
не може повторити успіх.
Все частіше Феттель починає зважати на
неспортивні аспекти життя:
він відданий захисту клімату і прав людини.
Перспектива бути гонщиком Формули-1 більше не
приваблює мене.
Незабаром сім'я стане його головним пріоритетом.
Для Себастьяна Феттеля існує життя поза трасою.
На жіночому «Тур де Франс»
нідерландська велосипедистка Лорена Вібес
святкує свою другу за день перемогу.
23-річна спортсменка перемогла, подолавши
175,6 км у масовому спринті.
На цьому п'ятому етапі відбулася серія серйозних аварій:
За 45 км до фінішу відбулося групове
падіння велогонщиків.
На сьогодні - це всі новини спорту.
Коротко про погоду:
сухість і посуха не покидають
нас цього літа. Але є і хороші новини -
сьогодні ввечері та завтра нарешті випадуть дощі!
Катя Горнеффер підготувала для нас детальний прогноз.
Нагадую про перегляд новин «heute journal»
з Крістіаном Зіверсом о 21:45 год.
До побачення!
Добрий вечір.
Якщо ви скучили за дощем, то сьогодні
можете насолоджуватися
вологим повітрям і хмарами на узбережжі.
Насувається все більше хмар
з півдня та південного заходу.
Тож очікуйте опадів з боку Альп уже вночі.
У другій половині ночі -
зливи та грози перетікають через Чорний ліс
у напрямку Оденвальду, Шпессарту, Рону,
а пізніше - у Заверланд.
На півночі, навпаки, небо ясне з мінливою хмарністю.
Там буде найнижча температура повітря.
Показники коливатимуться між +13 до +8°C.
Або збільшуватимуться до +16 - +13°C.
Найвищі температури повітря будуть завтра на
узбережжі Північного моря - +20 - +22°C.
Або ж досягнуть позначки термометра +23 - +30°C.
Ось у цьому районі буде трохи прохолодно,
небо затягнеться густими хмарами.
Там частіше йтимуть дощі з грозами.
Вдень, зі сторони Альп, можуть бути
нові сильні грози.
Можливо, вони навіть матимуть
штормовий характер, тобто, принесуть рясні дощі.
На Верхньому Рейні хмари, після дощів, розійдуться.
Приблизно на північ від Ганновера і
Берліна небо буде без хмар.
У суботу у напрямку сходу - зливи та грози.
У неділю теж, але вже зі сторони північного заходу.
Наступного тижня температура
повітря піднімається до позначки +30°C.
До зустрічі.